Why can't I tickle myself?
There are actually two types of tickle.
The first, knismesis, is a sensation of something moving lightly across your skin.
You can imagine why this sort of neurological alert...
...might be useful from an evolutionary standpoint.
You can intentionally induce this sensation with a feather on your arm...
...or by touching the roof of your mouth with your finger.
Though many species are susceptible to this type of tickling,...
...primates including humans show another more fascinating tickle sensation.
Gargalesis is a more direct tickle aimed at sensitive parts of your body...
...like your ribs, armpits or feet.
Sometimes this type of tickling was used as a form of torture.
Gargalesis is dependent on the element of surprise.
Recent studies have shown that if you try to tickle yourself,...
...the cerebellum, an area of the brain integral to locomotion,...
...sends signals to the cortex anticipating the resulting sensations and telling you to ignore them.
However, if someone else tickles us, our brain registers surprise and alarm.
Perhaps we evolved this mechanism...
...to distinguish harmless self-inflicted touches from potentially dangerous stimuli.
But ultimately, if you want to experience a true tickle sensation, get off the Internet.
Stop trying to tickle yourself and find someone nice enough to do it for you.